the new mayor of new york city has been
heralded as the savior he's going to
step in he's going to bring innovative
technology to the city i'm calling
[ __ ] ultimately what we saw was eric
adams was going to become the new york
city mayor and he started talking all
about bitcoin and ethereum saying he's
going to take his first three paychecks
claiming that he was gonna build the
capital of crypto no he's not he doesn't
even understand this stuff and here's
proof he just said yesterday that he
supports cryptocurrency but not crypto
mining what are you talking about that's
not how it works you can't have bitcoin
without mining you can't even have
ethereum right now without mining if you
don't support crypto mining you don't
understand cryptocurrency you don't
support cryptocurrency you're simply
virtue signaling you're simply trying to
ride the wave of the crypto interest and
say to yourself you know what if i talk
about it if i pretend like i actually
understand it if i pretend like i like
it then i'll get votes this is classic
politician nonsense and ultimately what
we have to do is we have to call out
these people when they start to step out
of line if you don't support crypto
mining you don't support
cryptocurrencies proof of work is
ultimately one of the best inventions in
technology over the last 20 years now of
course the environmentalists these
absolute morons who don't understand how
bitcoin mining works or what the
environmental impact is they're running
victory laps they simply have all their
lobbying power and got the ear of the
new mayor of new york city don't believe
me well here's a stupid quote bitcoin
mining could cost new yorkers millions
of dollars in energy bills while need
capping local businesses poisoning our
water and filling our air with deadly
co2 emissions the industry is already
expanding fast upstate and if we don't
act quickly outside speculators could
begin converting the city's peaker
plants into 24 7 fossil fuel guzzling
cancers on communities of color joseph
campbell just proved that he's an
absolute [ __ ] because you don't
understand how any of this works because
in states like texas you know what
they're saying they're saying the exact
opposite they're saying wow the bitcoin
miners they're actually capturing all of
the gas flaring they're preventing co2
from going into this uh air on top of
that now all of a sudden we're watching
in texas in the cold in the winter
bitcoin miners are shutting off their
operations to actually divert energy
back to the grid when it's needed most
bitcoin miners don't only make the
energy grid more stable they actually
make the environment better they use
renewable power they use up excess power
they capture gas flare and when
environmentalists start to talk like
this what you know right out of the gate
is they don't know what they're talking
about and they've got a lot of money
they do a lot of lobbying they love to
put their hands in the politicians
pockets but we can't allow it to happen
we must call them out early we must call
them out often the mayor of new york
city if he's serious about this not only
will he retract his statements but he'll
actually go and say we want to make new
york the capital of bitcoin mining we
want every miner in the country to move
here texas has done it they now have 10
of the global hash rate new york is all
talk and no walk and the mayor of new
york city he's proving he doesn't know
what he's talking about ultimately what
we can see here is another
environmentalist saying a huge thank you
to the new york city mayor for making
the distinction between cryptocurrency
and crypto mining in the local
government budget hearing today new york
can be the crypto capital without
letting mining destroy our environmental
goals what are these people talking
about they literally don't know what
they are saying you can't have bitcoin
or ethereum without crypto mining and
they just continue to prove that they
don't know what's going on if new york
new york city and the new mayor are
serious about becoming a hub for
cryptocurrencies they better pray they
better hope they better solicit every
crypto miner in the entire world to move
within their jurisdiction because
whether they like it or not mining is
here mining is staying and mining is the
bedrock for this industry if you don't
like crypto mining then unfortunately we
don't like you